en plein milieu de la mer Noire
d'énormes cargo à prêter par le
Programme alimentaire mondial avec 30000
tonnes de blé à leur bord direction le
Bosphore en Turquie pour ses navires qui
ont finalement pu emprunter le corridor
maritime humanitaire sous l'impulsion de
la Turquie en partie 16 gargots total
devrait pouvoir circuler de nouveaux ce
lundi le président erdohann l'un des
garants de la Corse sur les exportations
ukrainiennes signées en août dernier
c'était forcé de rassurer face au
spectre d'un retour de la pénurie
alimentaire
avec le mécanisme conjoint que nous
avons établi à Istanbul nous avons
fourni 9,3 millions de tonnes de blé
ukrainien au monde ce qui a permis de
diminuer relativement les effets de la
crise alimentaire la Turquie va
poursuivre ses efforts pour trouver une
solution à la crise alimentaire mondiale
en dépit des hésitations de la Russie
pour trouver un accord
un accord suspendu par la Russie
vendredi dernier en réponse à des
attaques contre sa flotte en Crimée ce
lundi le Kremlin averti qu’appliquait la
Corse en Moscou serait dangereux
dans un contexte où la Russie est dans
l'impossibilité de garantir la sécurité
des navires dans ces zones un tel accord
est difficilement applicable et cela
prend une tournure différente beaucoup
plus risquée dangereuse
de son côté dénonce un chantage à la fin
et des nombreux plusieurs dizaines de
navires encore bloqués par la Russie